hey welcome back to the monitor I am
Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired and i
am back from austin texas after a very
long week spent at South by Southwest
and came back to some excellent things
chief among them monday nights on A&E
there's actually a scripted show Bates
Motel why does that sound familiar what
was the motel from psycho and it's the
prequel to psycho kind of croton q is
one of the executive producers of lost
has developed a present-day prequel
series miniseries something 10 episode
run following a young Norman Bates and
his still living mother Norma Bates as
they kind of start a new life and take
over this motel Vera Farmiga plays the
mom and is fantastic as she always was
you loved her in the departed and every
other thing she's and she's a fantastic
actress and she really inhabits the role
of a woman on the edge and pretty high
more from Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory is a young Norman Bates the
creepy is ratcheting up slowly but it's
getting there and there is this thing
that seems like a mystery that's going
to thread its way through the season
that is a a nice little creepy thing
overall it's a great start just nice to
see A&E getting in the game a good TV
let's talk about comic books I have a
confession to make I hate zombies
seriously like nonsense Dawn of the Dead
has there been a zombie story that's
gripped me in any kind of way though
that has changed with the comic book
revival issue 8 is out this week revival
takes place in a rural Wisconsin town
where some members of the community have
managed to go from being dead to not
quite dead they're not exactly zombies
but there is something not quite right
about them so there is a sheriff and a
police officer who are investigating
certain cases there's a newspaper
reporter there's the police officers
sister who seems to be one of the newly
undead people it's a slow burn and its
really compelling I'm talking to you
because issue 8 is out this week but the
trade paperback is out which means you
can buy that for like ten bucks blow
through the first five issues and then
devour the next three and you'll be all
caught up this is the perfect time to
get in it is revival it's being
published by Image Comics let's talk
about movies
so director harmony korine has arguably
made more bizarre movies than any non
John Waters filmmaker working today and
his newest spring breakers continues
that trend though in a strangely more
accessible way it opens in wider release
this week it premiered last week you
have probably heard about it because it
takes X teen idol Selena Gomez and
Vanessa Hudgens and Ashley Benson and it
sets them loose as college best friends
who robbed a restaurant and then go to
spring break in Florida and fall in with
this insane drug dealer / rapper it is
really an investigation of kind of the
dead I'd Bacchanalia entitlement of our
youth today and it deals with all kinds
of crazy racial themes and does it in a
shrewder way than I would have given
Corrine credit for and this show is
absolutely stolen by James Franco
playing this dude named alien who seems
to be based on the rapper riff raff at
least riff raff says the character was
stolen from him regardless Franco is a
powerhouse in this thing you may be
tired of them but you owe it to yourself
to see his performance in this movie and
the cinematographer was the dude who
worked on enter the void so the visuals
are unreal also great score by cliff
Martinez who did Drive and Skrillex
working together it is about excess and
it's neon drenched and it's a lot of fun
that's it for the monitor this week
we'll be back next week more pop culture
but until then inspirational catchphrase
here